hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round one of this
year's Tata steel chess tournament it is
jujun women's world champion versus last
year winner of Tata steel tournament
Anish giri and he had an incredible run
last year I think in round three or
round four he defeated Magnus Carlson
and it was his first win over Magnus
Carlson in some 12 years if you haven't
seen that game do check it out I will
put a link to it will be the first link
in the description below and especially
now as he did not qualify for the
candidates tournament he is of course of
course looking forward to uh you know
show showing his absolute best in every
event that he plays and especially in a
local one such a stata steel now that
being said let's check out a nice photo
before we check out the the game some of
you said you would like to see some
photos before we actually check out the
game so there we have it Anish and Jun
before the game uh you can see that Jun
brought a glass of water Anisha doesn't
bring any Refreshments probably he's
just showing off his great form or maybe
he's is afraid that it will block his
oper logo uh on his uh suit but again
who knows maybe he'll bring something
later and you can also see that um uh
the pens that they are using are
absolutely the same which means that
they are given official pens by the Tata
steel committee or maybe by some chance
they brought the exact same pen uh
without um you know uh without it being
um organized in any form prior to the
event uh and if any of you guys spot
anything interesting on the photo as
usual do use the comment section to uh
inform us all now that being said let's
check out the game so Jen with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to E4 and Anish
goes for the Sicilian Defense Pawn to C5
he did make that 100h hour course on the
nidorf uh Knight to F3 and now Pawn to
E6 imagine that he makes a 100 course on
the nidorf Sicilian and then he doesn't
go for the nro he goes for this French
variation of the Sicilian and she
doesn't go for for the open uh battle
with Pawn to D4 she actually plays Pawn
to G3 and she slowly will be transposing
into the French defense or rather Anish
will be transposing into the French
defense Knight to C6 we have Bishop to
G2 Knight to F6 and now Pawn to D3 and
Bishop D7 sorry about that I just have
to fix something uh we have castles and
now Pawn to D5 striking in the center uh
we have Queen to E2 adding another
Defender to D4 Pawn so if captures you
can capture with the pawn and you don't
have to worry about a an early Queen
trade uh we have castles and now Pawn to
A4 and now uh what's interesting here
about this Pawn to A4 move is that it's
not uh White's most uh most optimal move
here or not one that's played usually
usually E5 is played here and after
Knight D7 Pawn to C4 you strike against
black strong Center but here we have
Pawn to A4 and it's a possession that uh
uh I I would very much recommend as this
is now the French defense this is no
longer the Sicilian Defense it's a
French defense where after E4 and E6
white doesn't strike with D4 but rather
white goes for this conservative D3 but
it's uh incredibly tricky and incredibly
strong uh one thing that uh once black
plays C5 usually French players want to
strike against the White Center and the
pawn will be on D4 but here C5 doesn't
really strike at anything and uh another
thing uh it's very uh easy for white to
get a very comfortable position for
example you'll put a knight on on D2 and
then if black ever captures any E4 or
plays D4 you can also play uh the the
Knight to C4 and without the D pawn and
the the possibility of B5 as you have
already played A4 the Knight on C4 could
be a monster for for the better part of
the game so it's a very interesting
system if you struggle playing against
the French and if you're reluctant to
learn a ton of theory you know give it
give it a try this this exact setup like
Queen on E2 knight3 Bishop G2 G3 for D3
and Ponto for castles uh Works wondrous
against the French so D captures an E4
by
D captures and now Pawn to E5 and now
Pawn to C3 stopping the knight from
coming to uh to D4 or B4 uh and now
there are a couple of games where Bishop
D6 was played but here we have Pawn to
H6 by an and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game I
think uh ding Len had this with black
against artmia in some online game but D
went for this bishop to E6 move Anish
sort of played H6 and both Bishop to E6
and H6 are top engine recommendation so
it's perfectly uh fine and okay now we
could go Knight B to D2 but Knight to A3
does seem to give a je engine more
options the Knight can now go to B5 to
C4 to C2 and also you are not blocking
your dark Square Bishop so okay Queen to
C7 and now Knight to D2 all adding more
uh The Defenders to this E4 pawn bishop
to G4 attacking the queen and also if
the Knight was on F3 you would just be
inviting this pin but now she kicks away
the bishop Bishop back to E6 and Now
Pawn to F4 and now if Bishop goes back
to G4 you can even put the queen on F2
so it's not a problem we have Pawn to A6
and now Knight a to C4 as we've
discussed uh the Knight finds a
wonderful Square on uh C4 and uh if you
if you if you can play B5 that's great
but if you can't uh then the Knight will
remain there for a very long time
luckily Anish can play Pawn to B5 in
this position but now Knight to E3 as
the E4 Pawn is still nicely defended and
the Knight now come to D5 to put
pressure on uh well Black's entire
position really we have Pawn to C4 and
now she plays Pawn to F5 which is the
which is the absolute strongest move
here now the reason why you don't go
Knight D5 right away is that once the
queen moves okay you could capture a
bishop but the bishop isn't really an
impressive piece here capturing the
Knight would be much better and after
Bishop captures for example Knight F3
now if Bishop G4 yes you can play F5 now
but it's not nearly as potent with the
bishop on G4 so before going Knight D5
she goes Pawn to F5 limiting the
mobility of um anisha's Bishop here uh
Bishop to D7 and now only now Knight to
D5 attacking the Queen Bishop and Knight
so Queen back to d8 and now King to H1
as both bishop and Queen have access to
this diagonal you do not want to run
into some trickery later on in the game
uh we have Knight to A5 uh it was only a
matter of time before Anish goes for
this maneuver the B3 square is a very
nice Square for this Knight eight
captures on B5 we have eight captures
and now what do you play here well uh J
Wun goes for Pawn to B4 as in any
position and so is is it in this one it
is the strongest move and either you
kick away the Knight which is really bad
for Anish because then White's
possession becomes excellent and Anish
will be stuck with this weak B5 pawn and
it's it's not just the we weak B5 Pawn
the entire chain will be broken at some
point uh or she he plays the absolute
strongest move and then we have a game
and that is C captures on B3 but that in
order to do that you have to sacrifice
The Exchange the The Rook on f8 so okay
Knight captures on E7 with check Queen
captures and Bishop to A3 with this
wonderful skewer here Queen back to d8
and of course she goes for The Rook Rook
uh Bishop captures Rook on f8 Queen
captures on f8 and now Rook F to B1 uh
Bishop to C6 on each shifts the
attention to the pawn on e4 of course
the queen will also help out the the
other Knight might also be able to help
out uh PA to H3 stopping Knight G4 and
also preparing to move the king to H2
and now Queen to C5 putting pressure on
the C3 pawn and now the question is what
do you play here well this is the first
moment in the game where uh where je
engine could have really taken uh uh uh
you know the game in a direction where
it's either she's playing for the win or
Anish manages to draw and that is by
giving up the C3 Pawn just going for
Knight captures and B3 right away and
after Queen captures and C3 now Queen F3
you just offer a queen trade and uh
Anish can't really uh avoid that
otherwise uh Rook to C1 will be
extremely strong going after the bishop
here so we'll have to trade here Queen
captures Bishop captures and then after
Knight captures on B3 Rook captures with
check Bishop captures Rook captures you
will have this position where okay Anish
is up a pawn but he's down the exchange
and you can't really capture the E4 Pawn
H if you capture a knight captures an E4
let's say just Bishop back to G2 and now
you don't have any discoveries G3 is
covered by the by the rook and black
will be in trouble now so if you can't
capture this more uh this Pawn this
means that the Rook will just capture
the B5 pawn and uh that's uh pretty much
it uh so that that was the way to uh
look for Advantage here but instead
Queen to D3 was played she went uh to to
defend actively the C3 pawn and now an
just goes Queen to F2 it's a very active
move with the queen also very annoying
one with the bishop and Knight eyeing
that E4 pawn and uh the problem is now
if you go Knight captur some B3 which of
course can be played it's uh it's just
forcing a draw Knight captures on B3 and
after Rook captures sorry Rook captures
on A8 Bishop captures on A8 Rook
captures on B3 there's Knight captures
on e4 looks impossible because you are
guarding the square twice but the
problem is if Bishop captures on e4
there's Queen E1 check and now black is
just winning so you can't capture with
the bishop you have to play Queen to d8
with Che check and after King to H7 pick
up the bishop on A8 but now it's just a
draw by repetition Queen E1 check King
H2 Queen captures on G3 and with access
to E1 and G3 it will be a draw by rep by
repetition so uh by by going for that
trade Jun basically forces a draw here
but she doesn't want that she wants to
play for a win so she goes Rook to B2
and okay King H7 Anish doesn't allow
that um Queen d8 to come with check that
we discussed Rook 8 to B1 and now Queen
back to B6 now you're definitely looking
at some discoveries as The Rook on B2 is
defended so once the Knight moves the
queen will be attacked so Queen back to
B6 and now King to H2 we have Rook to d8
going after the queen here Queen to E2
and now Rook to D6 just trying to
activate uh pieces as much as possible
uh Knight captures on B3 finally the the
Knight is eliminated and now Knight to
C4 of course Anish declines the trade we
have Rook to A2 and now Queen E3
offering a queen trade and she goes for
it Queen captures on E3 Knight captures
on E3 and the je engine's position is
much better here in fact she's the the
only one that can push this position for
a win H but only if you find the the the
only continuation that allows you to do
so it's an incredibly difficult position
and she was unable to do so in the
actual game but just for fun uh have
have at it pause the video and try to
find the absolute strongest move for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds seconds
here so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this incredible maneuver and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is night to C5 this is the crucial
move to uh to gain Advantage as it uh
not not only covers the E4 Pawn but also
stops Rook to D3 from going after the C3
pawn and now after Knight captures on G2
you do not capture the Knight right away
first you defend the pawn Rook the E4
and now with your E4 Pawn defended and
with the Rook unable to come to D3 now
doesn't matter what black plays if
Knight D7 you can simply trade here
capture the Knight and now it's equal
pawns five versus five but you have a
rook against the bishop and you will be
the one playing for the win here but she
misses this move she goes for the active
defense she plays Rook to E2 uh okay the
Knight is defended but now Rook to D3 is
allowed
sorry about that Anish goes after the C3
pawn and after Knight to C5 so she does
play the exact same setup only she had
to start with Knight to C5 uh but you
had to see that after Knight captures on
G2 you have to play Bishop to E2 because
the Knight doesn't have a way out and
now after Rook captures on C3 uh Rook to
B3 and now of course if Rook captures
then uh Rook captures this Knight but
now Knight E to G4 with check at least
Anish will mess up her Pawn structure
before capturing the Knight on C5 so H
captures Rook captures and now King to
H3 we have Rook to C4 putting pressure
on the pawn Here and Now Rook B to beat
you you cannot defend the pawn if I mean
you could but you have to make your
Rooks incredibly passive and then an he
just starts pushing the B Pawn B4 Bishop
to A4 B3 let's a bishop Rook to C2 and
the pawn is already you know a force to
be reckoned with so after Rook C4 uh
Rook beat to be2 is played and now
Knight captures on e4 he does win the
pawn bishop captures Bishop captures but
she also wins the B5 Pawn Rook captures
on B5 and now it seems like uh you still
have two Rooks against the rook and
Bishop but Anish is very sneaky he plays
Pawn to F6 and now uh you should play
Rook to F2 but she played Rook to B3 uh
and this just doesn't work Anish finds a
beautiful move here Bishop to C2 it
seems like it does nothing just
attacking the rook and you could move
the Rook go after the G7 Pawn looks
great the pawn is on a dark Square you
might be able to double up here go after
it the problem is the G4 Pawn is
undefended and now if the Rook moves for
example you play something even Rook B7
or Rook B2 doesn't really matter uh Rook
D1 and now the Rook has to move and you
will pick up this pawn and not just that
you will pick up this Pawn but you will
also pick up the F5 pawn and uh again
cover the D7 Square so white will again
uh be unable to double up and go after
the G7 pawn and here black would just be
winning so very sneaky move this bishop
to C 2 by Anish so she goes for Rook
captures and C2 she gives back the The
Exchange Rook captures and now Rook to
B8 uh okay now it's Anish who's up a
pawn and Anish the one pushing for the
win but how do you push for the win here
Anish can't bring the king to G6 and he
can't go back uh so what do you do here
okay of course you're not going to play
something like King H4 and allow
Checkmate in one uh but still how do you
push for something here well Anish will
play a few more moves Rook F2 Rook to E8
and now Rook back to D2 Rook to f8 Rook
to A2 and now Rook back to E8 so
obviously we settle for a draw here Rook
to F2 Rook to f8 we have Rook to D2 and
now Rook back to E8 Rook to D7 Anish
goes back and allows um jenin to
activate her King and she does King to
G2 with Pawn to H5 Anish not set happy
with a draw uh he wants to push for more
uh we have Pawn to G5 the correct way uh
now if Pawn captures you will eliminate
E5 pawn and and now Anish plays this
Rook to D2 check and uh out of nowhere
out of a position that you guys were
sure that wow this is a draw how does
anyone push for anything more here we
get to a position where one move will uh
ensure the draw and one move will just
give Anish the winning position so what
do you think you play here or rather
only one move will give uh Jun a draw
all the other moves will give Anish a
winning position so what do you think
the move is do do you see where the
where the King has to
go you know feel free to to consider it
a little
bit Yeah the the the King has to go to
H3 back to where it came from because if
it goes to F3 which was played in the
game uh it simply doesn't work and the
point is that after King H3 the only
winning idea that Anish has does not
work with the King on H3 now F captures
on G5 uh Rook captures on E5 and you
play G4 check which worked in all of the
uh lines except this one now King H4 is
just incredibly strong and you have
access to G5 so Rook H2 check is not not
a problem and you're just going to well
either gobble up these pawns or G6 then
captures and you will just start
checking the black king get the king
into the game so it will be a draw but
she had six minutes on the clock when
she made this move and had some 24
minutes uh and she played King to F3 but
now it doesn't work due to the exact
same idea F captures on G5 was played
Rook captures on E5 and now Rook to D3
check as the pawn pawns cover all of
these squares the King has to go back or
you go to E4 but then just Rook captures
on G3 is winning so she goes back King
G2 but now Pawn to G4 cutting off the
white king from entering the game and
this is just a much much worse position
than the one that we've discussed uh so
that's uh what you should do okay it
wasn't played in this exact same way
since Anish didn't start with f captur
on G5 Anish after King to F3 he went for
Rook to D3 check first but it brings us
to the exact same position F captures on
G5 Rook captures on E5 and after G4 uh
you have this position so she went back
Rook to d8 uh trying to keep the
blacking from entering the game but now
it's different Anish has Rook to D6 and
after Rook to C8 there's Rook to F6 she
he goes after the F5 Pawn Rook to C5
defending but now you can also bring the
king into the game Anish doesn't have to
rush this the best way to push for the
win here uh is to actually bring the
Rook to F3 and then bring the king into
the game because when The Rook is on F3
you also don't have to worry about
something like Rook C7 and pawn to F6 uh
so he goes Rook to f8 Rook to D5 and now
Rook to A8 we have Rook to C5 and now
Rook to A2 check first not going for
Rook A3 Rook to F3 but first giving a
check improving the position as much as
possible Rook A3 King G2 and only now
Rook to F3 so now there's uh there's
nothing she can do uh Rook to D5 was
played now the king comes into the game
and you could do it with King to H6 an
goes um uh back with the king king to G8
Rook to d8 with check King to F7 Rook to
h8 even going after the H5 Pawn now just
Rook captures on F5 there was no way to
to hold on to it and now it's three
pawns against one which of course is
winning pretty much regardless of the
position there are some where it's not
like if if this was the position then
it's a draw if the pawns are tripled but
they are not so here we have King to G1
uh and Rook to A5 now it's only a matter
of skill uh King to G2 and pawn to G6 we
have Rook to H7 with check King to F6
King to G1 and now Rook to A6 uh King to
G2 and now Rook to D6 Anish will set up
his um rook and king perfectly before he
starts advancing those pawns King to F2
uh King to E5 and now King back to G2
Rook to D2 with check we have King to G1
and King to E4 Rook to A7 of course it's
always better to uh check the check the
king from from the sides uh Pawn to to
G5 we have Rook to A5 going after the
pawn but now Rook to D5 the problem also
for J engine is that Anish can just
trade Rooks because now three pawns
against one is of course winning so Rook
to A4 with check King to E3 and now King
to G2 we have Rook to D2 with check King
to G1 and now Rook to E2 uh Rook to A3
with chck King to E4 and now Rook to A5
going after the pawn but then he just
played King to F3 and he was in this
position un move 80 that J engin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is uh
uh well if you go after the pawn which
is sort of what you want to do uh just
King captur and G3 threatening mate in
one and now after let's say King F1 Rook
H2 uh you will play something like Rook
to B5 try check checking the black king
king H4 and now after Rook B4 stopping
the advancement of the pawn doesn't
matter King H3 and after Rook B3 check
you will advance the pawn and after
whatever move doesn't really matter what
you play Just Rook A2 now if you go King
G1 then again Rook to A1 will result in
Checkmate and if Rook to C1 uh then King
H2 followed by G2 check and G1 Checkmate
so that's if you capture the pawn and if
you don't capture the pawn again Rook A3
check will be met with Rook E3 white
cannot afford the Rook trade and after
The Rook moves King captures on G3 again
a threatening Checkmate and you have
three pawns To None uh of course
completely winning so it was a really
intense game lasted for over 80 moves
and Jun had those two positions where
she could have pushed for advantage and
she could have gotten either a winning
position or Anish fights for a draw uh
but she gave Anish this one chance um
after Rook to D to check and you know
kudos to Anish for not just agreeing to
a draw just agree to a draw he decided
to push for a win uh he forced her with
six minutes on the clock to decide
between King H3 and King to F3 and it
was enough for her to make a mistake so
Anish starts uh at the tournament with a
win against women's world champion Jun
and he is definitely on track to defend
his title as last year's champion and
like I said if you haven't seen it first
link in the description below uh Anish
versus Magnus Tata steel 2023 amazing
game do check it out uh so yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed that uh I would like to
thank Welsh fan Mark Henley brandan
Michael mes Frank banner and best
content maker for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day